Narrator: Tonight
on "Shark Tank,"
there's more holiday cheer
than ever.
I brought a very special guest
all the way from the North Pole.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Hey!
Our gifts to you.
Ah, presents.
Stephens: It can remind us
of the comforts of being a child
and make us feel good.
Oh, my God,
I'm in love.
O'Leary: I'm deserving of one,
and I've been really good
this year.
I actually think
he's a pretty nice boy.
You might want to re‐check
that list, Mrs. Claus.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an entrepreneurial elf
who wants to bring
Christmas cheer to everyone.
Hey, look at this.
‐Hey!
‐Whoa!
‐Yeah!
‐What a happy sight.
[ Indistinct conversation ]
Ah!
Corcoran: Wow.
Hello, Sharks,
and Merry Christmas!
My name is Mitch Allen.
I am the founder, and head elf,
at Hire Santa.
I am offering 10%
of the workshop
in exchange
for 200,000 cookies.
[ Whispers indistinctly ]
Ohh! I mean dollars.
Sharks, I brought
a very special guest
all the way
from the North Pole ‐‐
Santa Claus!
Ho, ho, ho!
Corcoran: Hey, Santa.
[ Laughs ]
Everyone loves Santa,
but let's face it ‐‐
Santa's a very busy guy.
He can't be everywhere
at once.
That's why I started my company,
Hire Santa.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Cuban: It's a smorgasbord
of Santas.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Wow.
Mitch: To put you
in the Christmas spirit,
we brought...
A Black Santa!
We brought
your very own Christmas hats.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you so much.
‐All right, thank you.
Corcoran:
Wow, look at this.
[ Chuckles ]
Hire Santa uses
some of Santa's friends
to help spread
the Christmas cheer
whenever you need him.
We find
the perfect Santa entertainer
and take care
of all the details.
With Hire Santa, anyone can get
a visit from Santa.
Even if you're
on the naughty list.
Barbara.
[ Gasps ]
Barbara!
So, Sharks, who wants to play
in this reindeer game
and "sleigh" it
with Hire Santa?
‐Ho, ho, ho!
‐[ Laughs ]
Mitch, are you telling me
that Santa's not real?
I'm saying that Santa
is real,
and we've got some of Santa's
friends here today...
Okay.
...that Hire Santa uses.
Now, Santas, this may take
a little bit,
so let's get comfortable.
‐Ho, ho, ho!
Greiner: There's one Santa,
he's in the North Pole.
These are imposter friends.
That's all.
These are friends of Santa,
that's right.
Yes.
What up, Santa?
So, tell us,
how much does it cost
to hire a Santa friend?
It depends
on what it is.
The majority of our business
is actually retail.
So these are
long‐term engagements
where we put in a Santa
for many hours,
say 300 or 400 hours
during the course of the season.
So, that's
a different pricing
from let's say I want
to come to your home
to give
a very special one ‐‐
But what is that pricing?
And that is, say,
$200 or $300
for a personalized visit
from Santa.
But if you're having Santa work
for many days,
either at an office
or at a retail store,
what would that
be around?
So, it starts on the low end
of about $50 or $60.
These are long‐term ‐‐
An hour or a day?
Per hour.
These are negotiated rates
with long‐term contracts,
so it's not just a one‐off.
We have literally thousands
of Santas in our database,
so we're able
to provide Santas.
[ Laughs ]
You have thousands?
We've sent Santas ‐‐
we've sent Santas all the way
to China,
the Caribbean, Canada,
Mexico...
Greiner: Wow.
...and, of course,
all over the U. S.
I hired a Santa,
and he came over,
and he smelled like
a Billy goat.
[ Laughter ]
He was horrible.
That's why you need
Hire Santa,
because all of our Santas
are professionally trained.
How do you make money
when your whole business
is around Christmas?
We have six weeks,
from November 10th‐ish all
the way through Christmas Day,
is when we have Santas
that are out.
Mr. Elf, how did you come up
with the idea,
and how did you get
to be Santa's friend?
I want
to be Santa's friend.
[ Laughs ]
How did you get
to do that?
So, I've always
loved Christmas.
About 10 years ago,
I had a friend ask me to come be
Santa for their child,
and that was
when it really all changed.
The children just radiate love
and joy about Christmas.
It's really
a magical experience.
You can ask
any of these Santas,
they want to be Santa
because it touches their heart.
I started being Santa
professionally,
started getting lots of business
myself.
Grew so quickly. I've been
in national TV commercials.
I've been in some of the biggest
parades in the world,
and I couldn't handle
all the business.
So, being an entrepreneur,
what do you do?
You got too much business?
‐You delegate.
‐You hire. You hire.
‐Well, you ‐‐
‐Branch out.
You find somebody else to do it.
You start making ‐‐
you start making money
through other Santas.
So, locally,
in the Dallas/Fort Worth area,
I found other Santas
to do the gigs I couldn't do.
And so I created Hire Santa,
and now I get people
from all over the world
requesting Santas to come
to their home,
their office, or their ‐‐
Yeah, but where do you ‐‐
So, how's the year's ‐‐
Where do you so‐‐
Where ‐‐
where do you source
all the Santa ‐‐
I mean, obviously,
these guys are bikers
during the summer.
[ Laughter ]
There's a vibrant Santa
community online,
and so it's really
just networking,
it's online marketing itself
to get Santas
to come
to our site online.
What's your total revenues?
Two years ago,
we did $189,000.
‐Yeah.
‐Last year, we did $331,000.
‐This year, we're gonna do
$1.2 million
to $1.4 million.
O'Leary: Whoa, wait a minute,
that's four times ‐‐
And next year ‐‐ Hold on.
And the year after that ‐‐
The year after that ‐‐
That's a four times.
So 4x.
Yes, and the year after that,
we're projecting to do
over $2 million.
Whoa!
Okay, let's ‐‐
Well, how are you gonna get
the 4x jump this year?
We've already got a contract
with, uh,
the largest outdoor retailer,
and that is going to make up
most of the big jump
that we're having
this year.
So, what are you gonna use
the money for?
The ‐‐
The first thing is, uh,
I need to make a couple
of strategic hires.
I am wearing way too many hats
right now,
and so particularly
in marketing.
We have some online
training videos currently,
so I want to improve
our training videos
so that we can take
an average Santa
and make him
an exceptional Santa
faster than
we're currently doing.
Mitch, you didn't talk
about profitability.
So, let me just get
back to that.
So when we did $189,000,
we made $70,000.
When we did $331,000 last year,
uh, we netted $154,000.
And this year,
we're estimating between ‐‐
between $450,000
and $550,000.
I think it's lovely
to bring that kind of joy
into kids' homes,
but your revenue stream
really comes in
about six weeks
at the back half of the year.
I just like to be in a business
that is more consistent
throughout the year,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you. I really appreciate
your input today.
A lump of coal for you.
Cuban: What you've accomplished
is phenomenal, right?
I mean, it all comes down
to salesmanship.
But at the end of the day,
it's still a staffing business,
and it's about chasing
as many contracts as you can,
and that's
a brutally competitive business.
It's not a business
that I think
that you can build a moat
around, and so...
Although, that point ‐‐
...for those reasons,
I'm out, Mitch.
All right, thank you, Mark.
Really appreciate it.
John: I think that you're doing
an amazing job
at bringing all this happiness
to families.
It's just a business
that I don't want to be in.
So I'm out.
♪♪
What's great about your name
is it's targeted.
What's terrible about your name
is it's limiting.
And to Lori's point,
it's a 10‐week window
to generate revenue.
I don't even think
there's room in your deal
for an investor,
quite honestly.
It's kind of
your business,
and that's the only way
to work it.
So, sadly, I'm out.
♪♪
And then
there's only Scrooge left.
‐No!
‐Oh, no.
All sleighs lead back
to Mr. Wonderful.
That's what happens.
I'd like to take
this opportunity,
which is unique,
'cause you don't get to see
the real Santa.
Listen, Santa.
Yes, sir.
I collect watches.
Okay.
There's a watch called the
Patek Philippe 7511 blue face.
‐Oh, no.
‐[ Laughs ]
It's incredibly rare.
I'm deserving of one.
‐Not.
And I've been really good
this year.
‐It's very important.
‐Tell him, Santa,
you got to be nice.
You got to be nice
before you get presents.
Uh, Mrs. Claus
normally keeps the naughty
or nice list, so...
How's he doing?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Am I okay?
I actually think
he's a pretty nice boy.
Let me see what I can do.
‐Ah!
‐[ Laughs ]
Greiner: Oh, Mrs. Claus!
Okay, back to ‐‐
back to business.
Might want to re‐check
that list, Mrs. Claus.
So, you know,
I'm intrigued.
I was thinking
my social platform
could really promote
the you know what
out of all these guys.
Mitch: Absolutely.
But, look, this business
is not worth $2 million.
Um, here's my proposal.
I'll give you the 200k,
I want to be your partner 50/50.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh.
Excuse me, please.
Like I said ‐‐ Scrooge.
Silence.
Let me ‐‐
Let me talk with the elf.
This is a good deal for you,
here's why ‐‐
you get 200k,
you got a partner,
every dollar that comes out
is 50/50,
I go to work
for you, too.
I'm interested. I don't have
Santas in my portfolio,
and every year,
I need another watch, so...
There's a reason for that,
Kevin.
So, Kevin, I very much
appreciate the offer.
I've been an entrepreneur
basically my whole life.
Uh, 50%, um, I know
that you wouldn't accept
that valuation if I were looking
for another, uh, investor.
Well, what's your counter?
Now, I know that you own ‐‐
What's your counter?
I would counter
with $200,000
for 15% of the business.
Well, we're not gonna agree
on valuation, then.
What about
a different structure?
How about, um...
Mr. Wonderful,
how about we do this?
How about you do $200,000,
you make 50% of the profit,
but once you get
your money back,
you drop down to 10%,
and that remains your equity?
So, under
our currently model,
then you'll be getting this back
in less than two years.
Let's do this.
I like your deal. I want to make
a small tweak to it.
I want 20%.
On the long term.
Um...
John: I'll take
that original deal.
If you do it right now.
So, your deal ‐‐
But he's not Mr. Wonderful.
I'll take that original deal
you just offered him.
So, you get 50% of the profits
until you get your money back,
and then you'll be at 10%.
Yep.
I'll do it at 15%.
And so ‐‐
‐Yeah.
‐I want it at 15%, as well.
Uh ‐‐
O'Leary: I'll go to 15%.
You get Mr. Wonderful
or you get the discount guy.
You snooze, you lose.
Um, if you'll do 10%,
we'll get ‐‐ we'll do a deal.
Nah, I want to make
a little bit more.
I'll do it at 15%.
I'll do the 10%.
Oh, you're back in?
Yeah.
♪♪
From Santa and all the elves
at the North Pole,
Hire Santa would love
to do a deal with you, Barbara.
‐You got it.
‐There you go!
Oh, Barbara,
you stole that!
Greiner: [ Laughs ] She stole it
right out from under you!
It's a good deal.
It's a great deal.
And it's a happy business.
I so appreciate it.
Thank you.
You're a good negotiator.
Oh, thank you so much.
Barbara, I was stealing it
from Kevin.
You stole it from me!
It's an open game.
You know, let's go check
on the reindeer, Santas.
Elf, I helped you
with your deal structure.
I very much appreciate it.
Leave me the shoes.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I want the shoes.
Greiner: He should wear those
every day.
‐Thanks, guys!
‐Bye, Santas.
You are all
on my nice list.
‐Thank you.
‐Bye, everyone.
John: Later, Santas.
Mitch: Barbara has that twinkle
in her eye,
and she's gonna add
a tremendous amount of value,
so I had her picked out
right from the beginning.
Barbara usually has
a delayed fuse.
She was on this one
quick.
You know
what I like about it?
I'm getting my watch.
Cuban: [ Chuckles ]
‐Jingle...
‐Bells!
Ho, ho, ho!
All: Ho, ho, ho!
Well done, gentlemen!
Hello, "Shark Tank."
Congratulations
on 10 incredible seasons,
and thank you for helping turn
my dreams into a reality.
Together, we've brought
Mensch on a Bench
to over 150,000 Jewish families,
and we've brought a whole lot
of Funukkah to Hanukkah!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to a problem
with a favorite winter sport.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Nick Palermo
from Aspen, Colorado,
and I love skiing!
But these skis...
[ Grunts ]
...they get heavy
after a while.
‐[ Chuckles ]
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Kyle Allen
from Lafayette, Louisiana.
Nick and I are asking
for $50,000
in exchange
for 15% of our business.
I also love skiing,
but Nick is right,
these things do get heavy
after a while.
That's why
I invented Ski‐Z.
It's a caddy for your skis
that fits in your pocket.
Simply attach the Ski‐Z
to the front of the skis
using the handy
Velcro strap.
The wheel allows you
to roll your skis
straight to the slopes.
Palermo: You can push it,
you can pull it.
You can turn your skis
on a dime.
I've been in the ski industry
for 35 years,
and I have never seen anything
that makes
getting to and from the slopes
as easy as Ski‐Z.
[ Laughs ]
So, who wants to rock 'n' roll
with Ski‐Z?
Boom!
‐That's a pretty cool thing.
‐Yeah.
Does it roll
when it's in snow?
Absolutely.
No difference whatsoever?
No difference.
Do you guys have
a patent on it?
‐We do have a utility patent.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐It's solid.
‐Is it issued?
It is issued.
Utility?
Corcoran: What does it cost
to make
and what do you sell it for?
Kyle: The cost is $3.50.
‐And what do you sell it for?
$19.95.
Good for you.
Nice. Nice price.
O'Leary: And where are you
selling them
and what are
your sales like?
Our first year in sales
was ‐‐
Was this year?
No, our first year was
in 2013.
Wow.
In a matter
of about four months,
we did $230,000.
‐Okay.
‐Okay. And in 2014?
Uh, went to zero.
To zero?
‐Went to zero.
‐Why?
‐Do tell.
‐Sounds like a story.
We both had
very major personal problems.
I got cancer.
‐Oh, I'm sorry.
I found out everybody ‐‐
every male,
at some point in their life,
has prostate cancer.
Yeah, and if you're old enough,
you don't care.
Well, I still care.
My girlfriend is 32.
[ Laughs ]
What year was this?
2014.
And you're cancer‐free now?
Yep. Big time.
‐Congratulations.
‐That's good, congrats.
Kyle: Well,
let me just say this.
I think this is the best way
to explain our lives.
Do any of you know how to take
a 747 out of a nose dive?
You don't.
And that's what happened
to both of our lives.
In 2013,
I get home one day,
and totally blind sided,
I went through a divorce.
So, 2013's not a good year.
[ Laughs ]
And we're going into 2014
right now ‐‐
Okay,
so we got a goose egg.
What happens 2015?
Um, 2015 comes along,
I was working
with a manufacturing company
in the oil
and gas industry.
Oil fell down
to $35 a barrel.
I didn't have a paycheck
anymore.
Are we zero in 2015, too?
We were zero up to ‐‐
‐What happened 2016?
‐Let's keep going on yours.
And so 2016, we exceeded
our 100‐year floodplain.
South of Louisiana
went underwater.
We lost everything.
In the floodplain?
Yes, ma'am.
Mm‐hmm.
And ‐‐
So that's 2016.
You know, I kept getting
knocked down, but I get back up.
Okay, so that's a zero.
What about '17?
That's a zero, too.
Okay, let's get to 2018.
We're in 2018.
2018.
Where are we at, man?
Oh, we skipped '19.
We skipped 2019?
Oh, yeah, right,
I forgot.
‐Yeah, you skipped 2019, Barb.
‐Barbara, please d‐‐
‐We haven't hit that yet.
‐This just shows you ‐‐
Settle.
Barbara came back from
the future to be with us today.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, 2018,
we're here now,
everything's been a zero...
[ Laughter ]
...since 2013
when you did $230,000.
‐Right.
‐What is going on in 2018?
2018, we're projected to do
$575,000 in sales.
‐Wow.
‐So, you ‐‐ you're coming ‐‐
the product's coming back
in the market.
Things are good.
You've worked things out,
we're projecting $575,000
in sales.
How are you gonna
distribute it?
What's gonna happen here?
As of right now,
we are talking
to a distribution company
out of Denver.
Right. Right.
Are they a national distributor
for ski products?
How many have you actually sold
this year?
Yes, sir. Well, right now,
we haven't sold any this year.
Do you have anything
in inventory?
We have $350,000 worth
in inventory.
I bought those roughly
about five years ago.
Where did you get the
money to buy $350,000
worth of inventory?
Did you mortgage
your house?
I did.
I mortgaged my home.
Yeah, I mortgaged ‐‐
‐I have a question.
I mortgaged...
Ay‐yi‐yi.
So, um, do you have
any ownership stake in this?
Yes, he has 25%.
25%.
Is there anybody else?
My wife has 25%,
and I have ‐‐
I‐I'm remarried now.
And your wife is still
at 25%?
I'm remarried.
He's remarried.
Okay.
Your new wife.
New wife.
‐So, the new wife has 25%.
‐New wife has 25%.
‐Yes.
‐Oh, Kyle, you've been busy.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I have an offer.
Okay?
I'm gonna give you [Laughs]
$50,000 for 15%.
But you have
to accept it now.
‐Take it.
Cuban:
Don't look a gift horse.
That's what you wanted,
you have to say yes.
Take it. Right. Take it.
All right.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
It's exactly
what you asked for.
I'll simplify ‐‐ I'm out.
And I'm gonna be
really insulted
if I give you
what you ask for ‐‐
I'll complicate it ‐‐
$50,000 for 20%.
[ Laughter ]
Gee, that's hard.
Guys, guys, don't look
a gift horse in the mouth.
‐Yeah.
‐You have an opportunity.
Don't blow it.
‐Take the deal.
‐That you would even discuss it,
I'm feeling offended,
I'm feeling hurt.
Oh, stop being a crybaby.
What are you guys
gonna do?
Um...
What is your hesitation?
John: It depends on what Shark
you want.
I ‐‐ you know, I believe
in you two lover boys.
Let's go.
Doesn't sound like
they want either one of us.
Barbara, would you be willing
if, uh ‐‐
No.
O'Leary: Wait a sec.
What ‐‐ What's your question?
[ Laughter ]
You're taking too long,
you're pissing her off.
Greiner: [ Laughing ] She didn't
even hear what you had to say.
I'm gonna be here
when she's out,
don't worry about it.
What is
your guys' concern?
Um, my concern is if
we would need a line of credit
of, uh ‐‐ of $50,000
if we would need it. Would you
be able to help us with that?
You mean in addition
to the $50,000?
Yes ‐‐ Yes, ma'am,
if we would need it.
You already have
the merchandise.
As long as I have
the purchase orders,
why wouldn't I fund it?
Okay.
Of course.
But you should've made that
part of your deal,
because in essence,
you're asking for $50,000
and another $50,000.
And you're not
a very good boy.
[ Laughs ]
Cuban: So, what are you guys
gonna do?
You're right about that.
Guys, you have ‐‐
you have two offers.
What do you want to do?
Corcoran: Another conversation!
I've never seen
anything like this.
♪♪
Barbara,
we'll take the deal.
Well, hallelujah!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God.
I‐I feel like hitting you
with a ski.
[ Laughter ]
‐Unbelievable.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Looking forward to it.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Pleasure.
Thank all of you.
Good work, boys.
Thanks, guys,
appreciate it.
‐God.
‐Yes!
[ Laughing ] Got the deal!
[ Chuckles ]
Whoo!
This is just an awesome,
awesome opportunity
for our business.
I mean, it doesn't get
any better than this.
And it's been ‐‐ it's been
a wild, wild, wild ride.
Man.
They have no idea
what they did.
$300,000 in inventory.
$50,000 for 15%.
She got all the money
in inventory.
They need some help.
On a serious note,
they will sell like hotcakes.
‐They will.
‐They're the right size
to be at the point of purchase
on every ski shop counter.
Yes. Yes!
‐You're right.
‐It's just the perfect ‐‐
No, you need somebody
to deal with them.
Oh, you need
a sales force.
Those guys ha‐‐
are out to lunch.
No, there are sales forces
for ski shops.
Oh, my God.
Then Barbara comes back
from 2019 and cuts a deal.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a company
designed to bring fun
to every gifting occasion.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks, I'm Ryan.
And I'm Arik.
And we're...
Rynarik!
We're from
Minneapolis‐Saint Paul,
Minnesota, and today,
we're seeking $75,000
in exchange for 15%
of our business.
Sharks,
we live in a busy world.
As a freelance photographer,
I am always on the go.
One day, my little boy
looked at me,
he said, "Dad, how come
you're never home for dinner?"
And it just broke
my heart.
It was at that moment
I vowed never to miss a meal
with him again.
And that's why we invented
the Snack Hat ‐‐
the perfect solution
for balancing work and family.
[ Laughter ]
Snack Hat is
a patent‐pending neoprene cap
that easily slides
onto most heads.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, my God!
‐It comes complete ‐‐
It comes complete
with a stylish,
multi‐compartment plate
that's both dishwasher safe
and...wait for it.
Magnetic!              Magnetic!
Oh, gosh!
With Snack Hat,
you can work more
while still spending time
with your kids.
Snack Hat.            Snack Hat.
[ Laughs ]
Sharks, we know
how you don't
like companies
that just have one product.
So, rest assured,
we're a business
that has a whole line
of innovative solutions.
Like Bathe & Brew.
Shorten
your morning routine
by brewing coffee
in your shower.
‐Oh, my God.
‐And our best‐selling Pet Sweep.
[ Laughter ]
Double up,
play with your pup
while doing chores!
You see...
we solve problems
for everyone.
Even Sharks.
Here are a few more
of our products.
[ Laughs ]
I love the Pet Sweep.
Our gifts to you.
Ah, presents!
Mr. John.
Thank you.
I don't think we've ever had
a present we got to unwrap.
‐Thank you.
‐Go on, unwrap 'em.
Thank you, sir.
You bet.
Go on, unwrap 'em.
Okay.
Cuban:
I got cool stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Oh...my...God.
Corcoran: Oh, God!
John: I got a baby feeder
for the ‐‐
Virtual reality headset
for a cat.
[ Laughs ]
I got the Roto Wipe.
Corcoran: Oh, God.
Barb, what's yours?
I'm always looking
to save time.
I've got a Handy Hand.
That ‐‐ That one eliminates
your need for toilet paper.
‐To clean the toilet out.
‐Saves a lot of dough.
‐Oh, my God.
Sharks, our actual company
is Prank‐O.
We sell prank gift boxes.
We put a new twist
on gift‐giving
and add life to any party.
John: All right.
Greiner: Is there actually
something in here?
[ Laughing ] No!
That's the whole point!
‐Oh.
‐That's the whole point.
They sell the boxes,
that's brilliant.
Well, how disappointing.
Simply buy any
of our prank boxes,
you hide
your real gift inside,
and you sit back and watch
as the fun unfolds.
So, who wants to help us
prank the world...
Brilliant.
...and invest $640,000
for 8% of Prank‐O.
‐Oh, that ruins it!
‐You've got to be kidding me!
‐Ohh, you ‐‐
‐Wait, you changed it?
Wait, didn't you say
$75,000 for 15%?
‐That was a prank.
‐That was back in the...
‐It's the prank.
‐It was a prank.
This is
an entertainment vessel.
‐Ohh!
‐You put their real gift inside.
Oh, I got it!
This guy's a moron.
Cuban: And they ‐‐
Like your reactions... Ohh!
Since 2013, we've sold
$10 million of empty boxes.
Well, now you have
our respect.
John:
That's kind of weird.
How much will you do this year
in business?
This year,
it's, uh, $2.8 million.
O'Leary: Let's walk through
the business model.
Sure.
How do I find out
about Prank‐O?
How do you sell me
the product?
Do you have retail distribution,
or is it direct?
We do ‐‐
Uh, we have mass retail.
We're in mass retail
as well as, uh, on e‐commerce.
What do you sell them
at retail for?
What does it cost you
to make 'em?
What are your margins?
So, we make them
for 66 cents.
‐Yeah.
‐Online,
they sell for $8.
$8.
‐One box?
‐For a box?
‐One box.
Greiner: What did you guys do
before this?
What takes you
[Laughs] to this place?
Yeah.
So, I was, uh, one
of the, uh, early partners
of The Onion,
and, um...
‐The Onion?
‐The Onion.
Yes. Yes, ma'am.
Oh, really?
Good for you.
We were just a little newspaper
in Wisconsin.
The Onion?
What ‐‐ What is it?
It's a satir‐‐
a satirical newspaper.
I did that for 20 years,
and, um,
we had this box
in our e‐comm store
that was flying
off the shelves,
and it was
some designer guy,
outside designer guy
that had it. So...
‐It was you.
‐Yes.
I met Arik.
A couple years later,
and a few happy hours later,
we, uh, started Prank‐O.
What's your background?
I'm, uh ‐‐ 20 years,
I've been, uh ‐‐
uh, self‐employed,
a graphic designer,
and this hit me
way back when,
watching my nephew
open a toaster oven ‐‐
it appeared to be
a toaster oven.
His parents put
the real video game inside,
and it was just
this great moment at ‐‐
at ‐‐ at Christmas...
It's brilliant.
...that everybody loved.
And within a week,
I started ‐‐
started
my first prototype.
And you do it three weeks
out of the year.
So, what do you do
the rest of the year?
Well ‐‐
That's what we want
to talk about.
Yes.
We want to ‐‐
There's ‐‐ There's 541...
Billion gifting occasions.
...million
gifting occasions ‐‐
birthdays, anniversaries,
uh, graduation,
Father's Day, Mother's Day.
And what we want to do
is market to those people.
So, a couple questions.
So, last Christmas,
your last shipping season,
what did you do in total revenue
and what was your net profit?
Okay, so, that's where I need
to, uh, clarify some things.
We started this
in 2013.
2016 and '17, we, uh ‐‐
uh, we got distracted.
We had other
seasonal opportunities,
novelty gifts,
had to deal with Asia,
and, uh, molds,
and, uh...
Set‐up fees.
...set‐up fees ‐‐
You were making products
like that magnet head dish?
Yes.
Cuban: You tried to create
physical products...
Yes.
...and expand your business
on e‐commerce
because we have traffic,
we're funny...
Yes.
Yep. Right.
Bottom line is
we made mistakes,
we lost focus,
lesson learned.
Okay, put that ‐‐
‐Okay.
‐Well, but what's your debt?
$1 million long term.
How much cash do you have
in the bank?
Uh, right now, it's, uh ‐‐
tightest time of the year.
We're working off
the line of credit.
How much have you pulled
on your line of credit
as of right now?
Uh, $3 million.
Oh!
Oh.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Let me just share with you
my thought.
I think very funny, clever idea
and all of that.
But I like things
that sustain
and are sold more
throughout the year.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Uh, structurally,
the business is not investable,
so I'm out.
Thank you.
The way I see your business is
you have $1 million in debt,
you have zero money
in the bank, you have no profit,
you have skinny margins, and
you're valuing your business ‐‐
I can't do the math, but
it looks like around $7 million.
I don't get it.
I'd love to see numbers
I can get my teeth into.
I‐I'm sorry,
but I'm out.
♪♪
Your problem is you're trying
to do too much.
The refocus is on Prank‐O,
that's what I'm saying.
What are you doing,
Mark?
Look,
I'll make you an offer.
‐Okay.
‐Right?
But you're gonna have
to listen.
Okay.
You've got a great product,
you've got great comedy minds.
But your track record
speaks for itself.
And ‐‐ And I‐I don't mean
any disrespect,
'cause all entrepreneurs go
through this.
No. That's ‐‐ that's fair.
Right?
I‐I've ‐‐
I made a mistake.
We all learn, right?
So, I'll offer you
the 640k.
Okay.
But I need 25%
of your business.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Ryan and Arik came in
seeking $640,000
for 8% of their
prank gift box company, Prank‐O.
Mark is interested, but he wants
more than three times
the equity
they initially offered.
‐I'll offer you the 640k.
‐Okay.
But I need 25%
of your business.
Okay, interesting offer,
let me give it to you
a different way.
I'm in this space
in a big way.
Yes, sir.
Lovepop cards.
Yes.
Potato Parcel.
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
I live this in and out
about rotating SKUs,
the seasonality of gifting.
There's two things
I can do for you.
I can smooth out the seasonality
a little bit.
But the real added value
is to get your website
so it becomes 10%, 11%, 12%,
13%, 14% of your business
direct at 8 bucks a pop.
That I do because
I have millions of names
that already go
through my gift cycle
at three different companies,
all right?
Okay.
I'm gonna give you
the $640,000.
I want 38 cents royalty
on every unit.
That's it, no equity.
Get $640,000
and you get my team,
and we'll fix this business
for you.
Guys, the only sales pitch
I'll add for myself
is we test it with the Mavs,
you know...
I can spend a buck a pop,
right,
to go out there
and do custom,
and we come up
with something fun.
The Dirk Nowitzki Shot Guide,
or what ‐‐ whatever it is.
It's up for you to ‐‐
you guys to decide.
Don't let Mark do
the writing.
That wasn't very funny.
[ Laughs ]
But that's not enough.
I‐I need you
to sell 1.7 million packages
just to get my money back.
Listen ‐‐ listen ‐‐
listen to me.
Liste‐‐ Kevin. Kevin.
I got a ba‐‐ I'm gonna bump
this business up
big time.
Yeah, but Mark is the buyer,
as well.
Yeah, I'm the buyer,
right?
Yeah, I got that.
But that's 15,000, 20,000 units.
So what?
And so if it works
for me ‐‐
it works for me, it's gonna work
for every sport,
every university.
We can go get license,
we can get NBA licenses.
Would you go 15%?
No.
No?
20% with a line of credit?
No. It's got to be 25%
because it's gonna take
a lot of work,
and it's gonna take
a lot of guidance.
I, uh...
There's no equity,
Mr. Wonderful?
‐It doesn't make sense.
‐No?
It doesn't make sense.
You know...
And then you want ‐‐
You would ‐‐ you would ‐‐
you would ask
for 38 cents?
Per unit, I'll have to sell
a million ‐‐
‐Is that indefinitely?
‐I have to sell 1.7 million
of these
to get my money back.
Right, but indefinitely?
Indefinitely?
‐Is that indefinitely?
Yes! It's a partnership
of three guys,
that's what this is.
What I try and do
is expand
the direct‐to‐customer sales
without a middle man
in the middle
as we do at Lovepop.
Right.
We covet that direct sale
because we capture the name!
Mm‐hmm.
And we sell those people
25% again on every season.
That's the key
to your business.
No, it's not.
And it ‐‐ it absolutely is
the key to your business.
I'll tell you the key
to your business,
besides simplifying, is going
to e‐commerce retailers
and having them o‐offer this
as an option, an up‐sale option.
Put it in a ‐‐ you know,
"You bought this,"
put it in the front ‐‐
You do that, too,
but you're not capturing
any value in your own name.
On a seasonal business,
where there's
a birthday involved,
or there's a gifting period
like Easter or Christmas,
you need the name,
because 25% of those people
buy again at full margin.
You mean
the mailing list.
Yes!
That's how you do it.
I have to say,
you can't afford his 38 cents.
Sure you can.
Could you ‐‐ Could you ‐‐
Would you ‐‐
Would you consider 20%?
‐No.
‐No?
♪♪
We've got to learn
from our mistakes in the past,
and thin margins killed us,
so, um, I respectfully,
uh, decline your deal.
Mr. Cuban?
Corcoran: Good move.
Let's go sell
some Roto Wipes.
Yes, sir. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations. I love
The Onion, by the way.
‐Thank you.
‐What a great publication.
Appreciate it, man.
Congratulations.
‐Thank you. I appreciate it.
‐We'll have a lot of fun.
‐All right, guys, good luck.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you.
Walther: We know how
to make people laugh,
and, uh, Mark understands,
obviously, business
and how to scale
businesses.
So, with, uh, our ability
to create comedy,
and Mark's ability
to grow a business,
it's gonna be
a great partnership.
We got a deal!
We got a ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
That's actually funny.
We missed it.
Narrator: Last season,
we watched brothers
Michael and Brian Speciale
make a deal with Barbara
for their cozy loungewear,
The Comfy.
♪ Joy to the world ♪
♪ The Comfy's here ♪
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Michael: When we went
on "Shark Tank,"
we did so with no sales
and just a couple
of prototypes.
After making a deal
with Barbara, within five weeks,
we hit our first million dollars
in sales.
It's called The Comfy.
Brian: We've sold out on QVC
six times already,
and so that's made them
up their order
to about 400,000 units.
Now it's been
less than a year,
and we've just hit
$15 million in sales.
McGee: Welcome to Bed Bath.
Corcoran: You know these great
entrepreneurs.
Brian, nice to see you.
Michael.
There's so much
that goes into
actually getting
on a store shelf.
I've had to help them
with sourcing, marketing,
packaging, and getting it
into a big‐box store.
We want to get behind this
in a big way.
We want to put it
in over 11,000 stores.
Wow!
This is the fastest
I've ever seen a product
go from prototype to retail
to a total rollout
in all of
the Bed Bath & Beyond stores.
It's gonna be a home run
for us.
Michael: To be part
of the "Shark Tank" family,
to be part of something
that has been
such an important part
of American culture
over the last 10 years
is probably the deepest honor
that we've ever had.
Fabulous!
Little did they know
that in one year,
they were gonna be
multimillionaires
simply because they had
the stamina to stay the course
and keep believing
in that dream
and, of course,
coming on "Shark Tank."
I'm so excited
for you guys!
We hope
that we can show people
that the American dream
is achievable.
We had a great idea,
and we did something about it.
Anybody else
can do it, too.
All: Happy holidays!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business
inspired by an old‐fashioned
breakfast staple.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks, I'm Sam Stephens,
and I'm the founder of OatMeals.
I'm seeking
a $500,000 investment
for 20% of my business.
All of us have some
sort of connection to oatmeal.
We were fed it growing up,
and it can remind us of
the comforts of being a child,
of being home,
and make us feel good.
It's also pretty awesome
that it's one
of the most healthy foods
on the planet.
OatMeals is
a build‐your‐own oatmeal café
where we put modern twists
on an old‐fashioned favorite.
We serve steel‐cut, hot oatmeal
with nearly 80 toppings,
but what really makes
my café shine
are my nearly 30
signature bowls
ranging from healthy to sweet
to even savory oatmeal
with nontraditional toppings
like Parmesan cheese,
truffle oil,
poached eggs,
and even bacon.
Wow.
I'm ready to expand OatMeals
all across America.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to top off my oatmeal
with some cash?
‐Feed me.
‐We want the oatmeal first.
Cuban: Feed me.
Yeah, do you have
truffle oatmeal?
Yes!
Feed me.
I have some samples
for you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, so I'm serving you guys
the truffle risotto,
and I added bacon
to this one.
Truffle?
Oh, bacon.
Yes.
That's like talking dirty
to me.
So, the truffle risotto is
shaved Parmesan cheese,
truffle oil, bacon,
sea salt, and pepper.
What are the other ones?
So, then the hot date
is bananas...
Wow!
...pecans, dates,
uh, honey,
our house granola,
and some peanut butter.
And then lastly,
the antioxidant awakening.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Awaken me.
Awaken me.
The truffle is amazing!
‐Yay!
‐Oh, my God.
Is the pomegranate one
a dessert?
Stephens: Well, it's actually
pretty healthy
because it has
the Greek yogurt...
That's pretty good.
...chia seeds,
dark chocolate chips.
‐Oh, my God, I'm in love.
‐Awesome.
‐Oh, this is incredible.
‐It's so good.
Corcoran: I love the bacon
with the cheese.
Yum!
Ohh!
John:
And I hate oatmeal!
It's like a dinner,
not a breakfast.
So, um, in the shop...
This is delicious!
...people really didn't know
about savory oats,
but you can get all the benefits
of eating oatmeal
for lunch or dinner,
not just for breakfast.
This is great!
‐What is it?
‐Just grab it, yeah.
What are the caloric
and carbo metrics to this?
So, in the shop,
the bowls come
in a baby, mama,
or papa bear size ‐‐
8, 12, or 16 ounces.
The baby bear, plain,
starts at just 110 calories,
the mama bear, 150 calories,
and then the papa bear,
about 180.
Why don't you give us
some prices on those, as well?
Yes, um, the baby bear starts
at $4.25,
mama bear, $5.25,
papa pear, $6.25,
and that includes two toppings
of your choice.
Each additional topping
is either 50 cents
or 25 cents.
We get a lot of different things
that come into the Shark Tank,
a lot of different foods.
These are some of
the most delicious things
ever brought in here.
Thank you so much.
And the interesting thing
is they're all very different.
Exactly.
What is the game plan here?
This is a store
that sells oatmeal?
It is, um...
Single location?
I can show you a picture
of the store.
That's the exterior.
I'm in Greenwich Village
on West 3rd Street
in Downtown New York City.
You want me to invest
in this single store?
Yeah, so I'd like
to expand firstly
in New York City,
either in Midtown Manhattan ‐‐
So you want to open
more locations?
‐Yes.
‐How did you come up with this?
Stephens: So, I had this idea,
but I really didn't know
how to make it happen.
I was working in
the investment banking world
as an executive assistant
for many years,
then I finally went
to culinary school
while I was working full‐time
because I knew
I really needed the credentials
as being a chef
to make this happen.
So, after I became a chef,
I finally, you know,
left my career,
and made this happen.
I've been open for six years,
the business has been growing
every year.
Can you tell us if it's been
profitable and for how long?
So, over six years, um,
I've made $2.5 million.
What about this year?
This year, I'm on track
to do $500,000.
How many square feet
is the store?
It's 380 square feet.
Sam, what were your profits
last year?
So, uh, $470,000 last year
gross,
the net was $45,000.
‐After you paid yourself?
‐Yes.
And what did you
pay yourself?
Not much. [ Laughs ]
Probably about 40 grand.
Corcoran: And how do you
support yourself
if you're only taking out
$40,000?
I know New York is
so expensive.
Do you even have the money
to eat your own oatmeal?
[ Chuckles ] That's basically
all I can really afford to eat.
[ Laughs ]
Um, I'm also a spokesperson
for Quaker Oats.
I was approached
by Pepsi Quaker...
You are?
...right after I opened
the store.
Um, I've had some really
great press just organically.
And they pay you
for that?
They do. My contract with them
is $60,000 this year,
it's not much.
Cuban: No, that's awesome.
You're making more
with Qu‐‐ with them
than you are your store.
That's awesome.
Have you ever thought of
taking your different oatmeals
and packaging them so that they
could be in freezer sections?
Absolutely. Um, because
I always thought it would be fun
to do a packaged food line.
You know, getting oatmeal
out of the breakfast aisle
and into the rice
and pasta aisle.
I think you face
a pretty high mountain to climb
because the perception
of the consumer in America
with oatmeal is going
to be forever with breakfast.
Very creative, product's great,
everybody agrees.
But I don't think
about eating oatmeal
after 10:00 in the morning,
like 99.999% of the ‐‐
No, that's not true.
That's not true at all.
Let me finish, Mark.
Let me finish.
But I'm more concerned
about the numbers.
350 square feet, you need
to be doing about $1 million,
$1.2 million a year to make this
an interesting opportunity
to expand to more locations
or to franchise,
because you're basically making
no money.
You can't even live in New York
for $45,000.
There's rats that are making
more money than that.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Right.
You are not worth $2.5 million
as an opportunity.
I'm out.
John: I think
you're figuring out ‐‐
I mean, it's clear
you're the oatmeal whisperer,
but, you know,
at $500,000,
I think even if you had
some good years
on the second or third store,
it would take me 12 years
to get my money back.
So I'm out.
Stephens: Thank you.
Greiner: Well, here's one of
the problems ‐‐
locations, right?
Mm‐hmm.
My Bantam Bagels, they came in
with one bagel ball
that was stuffed
with great cream cheeses
in different flavors,
and we got
into Starbucks nationwide.
That was pivotal.
And then got into
all the grocery stores.
And now we've done
$40 million.
I'm trying to think
how could we try
to replicate that model?
And the big question
really goes to you.
So, are you open to packaging,
selling in retail?
Like, doing a completely
different model.
Absolutely.
All right, then I'm gonna
give you an offer.
I'm gonna make it contingent,
though,
on if you will figure out
packaging.
Pick top flavors.
We'll try to bring it
to Starbucks.
I'll give you the $500,000,
but I want 33.3%.
I want to be a third partner.
'Cause it's gonna be
quite a bit of work.
‐Okay.
‐I have another offer for you,
but I have a whole different
spin on your business.
I believe you could have
a very successful business
if you brought
your business onto a cart
and serve oatmeal
to corporate America
in the morning
and risotto for lunch.
I don't think
it's that much of a change.
And I'd be happy to give you
the $500,000,
but I want 50%
of not your store ‐‐
no interest in something
that doesn't make money.
But I'll give you
the $500,000
if I could own 50%
of the cart business
and let the money be
entirely used
for making that business
a reality.
That doesn't have a contingency
like Lori, right?
Well, I guess you could say
the contingency
is the money's only to be used
for the cart business.
We must be on the planet Zutron
right now.
Go away, be quiet.
You are the store
that makes no money,
have two half‐a‐million‐dollar
offers.
That never happens
on the planet Earth.
So you better think about this
right now
and make a decision.
Sammy,
what do you want to do?
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Sam has two offers on the table
from Barbara and Lori
for her oatmeal restaurant,
OatMeals,
but they have
very different plans
for what to do
with the business.
We'll try to bring it
to Starbucks
and to the frozen food
sections ‐‐
Corcoran: But may I tell you
why you should really
do the deal with me?
Because I picked up
Cousins Maine Lobster,
they never thought they could
move off of one truck.
They now have 40 trucks,
they have $50 million in sales
in four years.
Let me tell you,
the key to that deal
was looking at it
differently.
The one liability
every entrepreneur has
when they have
a slow start financially
is they're too close
to the problem to see it.
Your problem is not
your ingredients,
your dedication,
the product you're making ‐‐
You're getting
rave reviews!
Your product is
you're literally
physically stuck
in that store.
So, you're really crazy
not to give this a shot,
and I wouldn't certainly
put my money into it
if I didn't totally believe
in it.
I could see clearly
from a mile away
how to expand the business,
see how to untie that knot
and get it pushing forward.
Lori,
would you consider 30%?
Ugh!
30%?
It's the wrong
business model.
Let's meet at 33.3%.
I mean, we ‐‐
I want to be a third partner
because we're bringing
a lot.
Cuban: Remember,
it's a contingency, Sam.
So, if you don't get
that distribution,
you don't have a deal.
Well, you're gonna get it.
I think Barbara's deal
is safer for you.
I mean, I go with my gut.
I mean, I think
this is something.
I wouldn't give the offer
if I didn't think
it was something
that was going to happen.
But you can't guarantee
Starbucks, Lori.
You can't do that.
Barbara can guarantee.
‐They sell oatmeal already.
‐With the way she wants to go.
You got to knock
the other guy out.
Sam, one offer is a bet
on distribution
for a product
you don't have.
The other offer is taking
what you already do
and replicating
in a more profitable,
more efficient format.
Sammy,
what do you want to do?
♪♪
Lori, you have a deal.
‐Ugh!
‐Oh!
‐Oh, wow!
‐Great.
[ Laughs ]
‐Barbara.
‐I am shocked!
John: 'Cause you were being
greedy, Barbara, with the 50%.
‐Wow.
‐No, not at all.
Just on that little side.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, I'm excited.
Thank you.
Me, too.
Yeah.
Thank you.
‐Congrats.
‐We're not on the planet Earth.
Thank you guys very much.
‐Congratulations, Sam.
‐Good luck.
Corcoran: The worst news of all
is she wasn't smart.
Stephens: Ultimately,
I went with Lori
because I have seen the success
that she's done
with Bantam Bagels,
and I followed that,
and I don't think I'll have
any regrets tomorrow.
Um, you know, I‐I came in
initially wanting a deal
with Barbara,
but, um, Lori's offer
just sounded really great.
You just stole
millions of dollars
from this babe and sent her down
the wrong path.
What?! That's crazy.
You never even make oatmeal.
I make it,
it doesn't freeze,
it's not even good
the next morning.
There's no chan‐‐
You really sold her
a bill of goods.
Barb, honey, you're just upset
because I won.
Of course I'm upset
that I lost.
[ Chuckles ]
What do you think?
Well, Barbara,
you were asking 50%.
50% of an entirely
new business.
I'm eating my oatmeal.
Lori, that ‐‐
that was a dumb deal.
You made a dumb deal.
Oh, my God.
‐Dumb. Dumb.
‐Any time it's not your deal,
it's a dumb deal.
‐No, she made the dumb deal.
No, Lori didn't make
a dumb deal.
Sam ‐‐
I didn't make
a dumb deal.
She made a dumb deal,
you made a dumb deal.
You deserve each other.
Oh, my God, Barb.
I agree with that.
You're acting, you know,
a little jelly.
It's painful.
[ Chuckles ] Jelly.
[ Meows ]
♪♪